it's been a while since we covered a
what culture video excited to do this
one today
and this is the first time we're going
to be doing what culture gaming
10 video game characters that react to
you being
a creep very excited to check this out
beginning back into gaming so much goes
to tsushima
just got in the mail today my girlfriend
she actually bought that one so
she's gonna be playing it all weekend
she because she doesn't go back to work
till next week so when she's done
i'm gonna pick it up and then hopefully
do a game review on this channel and
have them be in a creep yeah well i mean
you're white ain't that right nick
cannon that's what we do
just creep and we're bad people
back in the 80s and 90s everything was
so much more
innocent yes video game adverts you know
which one does it
is uh merrell and a metal gear solid
i mean look at her being tied to a
and just wanted to save things kill
things or climb on things
then 3d came along and it didn't take
long to realize that piloting a floating
camera around
meant that you could get up to all sorts
of nefarious business
i say you but i mean holy ass teenagers
who the industry only continued to
market towards including scores of
references to this sort of stuff in the
games themselves
with so much time and experience
invested into the industry over time
though
developers have come to know our every
move and if you try robbing a video game
character of their dignity
they're gonna fight back i'm scott from
moreculture.com and these are 10 video
game characters that react to you being
a creature
with this title please stop staring hey
i thought we're gonna do more recent
games
start with something that i remember
from my childhood no it's not the
section of the game where you need to
identify merrell from his signature
asswiggle yes that actually happened but
something altogether more pedestrian
see in metal gear solid you can hear you
look at her rack
up the game's secret photos that hit
shots of the developers in various
places
but stared directly at merrell and
cheats start to blush
now blush in a ps1 sense meant that her
entire character model turned into a
tomato
but keep staring and meryl won't just
tell you to stop
she'll straight up level snake with a
devastating vomit
it's like your parents always said don't
stare
number nine hatsune miku wow project
diva f
arguably one of the most important
articles
software voice bank hatsune hiku took
the world by storm across the late 2000s
and i'm reliably informed she still
matters today as for that initial burst
of popularity though it meant that miku
was everywhere from touring with lady
gaga to appearing on david letterman
really rhythm action video games just so
that you could buff along with it
in projectiles clearly the devs realized
the propensity for a 16 year old virtual
girl
to be ogled out from all directions
thereby implementing a failsafe
should you try when viewing hatsune's
character model in the photo studio mode
to rotate her into an upscale position
the game removes her character model
altogether saying that
the character cannot be displayed please
change the orientation
placement size or reset their position
that should teach you
number eight trying to embed every new
character immediately
oh i remember being a supremely
influential and
important sci-fi franchise loaded with
explanations for everything
from race relations to how guns fire or
being a game that lets you bear anyone
in your immediate vicinity
if it comes to the aliens tried to make
a comment on it in the second game
come the point in the game where you
recruit the superpower
she'll head down to her quarters until
you manually engage in another
conversation
do so and you can embark on one of the
more emotive and rewarding relationships
in the whole trilogy however as
jack is very much caged off and the
sufferer of various abuses in her past
she'll point blank ask you if you're
only pretending to care
because you want to have some sex answer
with i want you
and before you can say multi-colored
endings you're going at it right there
on the ship's pipework
oh wow jack ultimately wanted to be more
than a glorified masturbation session
and sleeping with her here actually
locks her off as a romance option for
the rest of the game
really leon the perfect resident evil 4
or
you might have gathered if there's one
type of perversion the gaming industry
has inspected i do love this game
character once the advent of 3d cameras
became a thing though you can just
imagine the horrified realization on
behalf of the developers
when they realized any player could just
manipulate a few points to be as creepy
as possible
here is where the societal standards of
the time came in
as the vast majority of times that this
happens in games bless that laser sight
not in resident evil 4 though as any
attempt to use the a mode to stare up
ashley skirt and shield bellow to the
heavens
screaming what are you looking at and
calling leo really
i never did that
i never did that you must be a moral
gamer
particularly creepy that then can't be
removed from that player's profile
in lollipop chainsaw creative oh
notably over the james and sexualized
and knew that players would swoop the
camera in to try and see a bit more than
what they were supposed to do
however not only does main character
juliette stalin slide her hand in place
to stop you being a big old pivot but
continue to do it or move the camera
around
and the trophy i swear i did it by
mistake will forever
according to true achievements of the
2016
70 of them have this attack
though i guess good going number five
cheating on your girlfriend in public
catherine catherine is a masterful deep
dive into what it's like being a
post-university mid-20s city living male
not knowing what the hell you're
supposed to be doing with your life
it's mainly focused on this escape it
puts you in control of vincent
a man who's been dating now pregnant
girlfriend catherine for a long time
with a c to turn up and him to wake up
next to her the following morning
what follows is a multiple ending
extravaganza of voyeurism and a truth
telling the game letting you know what
players all around the world are also
choosing when certain whitey questions
pop
up brilliantly though as part of the
reality of having a girlfriend while
another tries to tempt you away
is catherine sending you salacious
pictures of herself that you can view on
your phone
try to do this in the game's cafe
surrounded by your friends though
and vincent will put his phone away
saying that he can't do this here
where can you safely emotionally cheat
on your partner in peace
why in the cafe restrooms sitting on a
toilet seat hunkered over your phone as
you browse through to your hotspot
just like real life number five
[Music]
which for the record is a putridly
growth practice still employed by the
gunner press
nia automata introduced what's meant to
be a joke that sold calibur 6 then tried
to run with
in near two beats behind is forever
poking out between a dress that's
animated to barely conceal it in a
bizarre method of seeing more though
you'll need to rip two b's chipset to
self-destruct as that blows the entire
bottom half of her character model's
clothing
and kind of props but kind of not goes
to create a yokotaro
who said that this feature was only in
the game because he really likes girls
as for soul calibur 6 is a playable
character
however one of her victory screens sees
the camera swoop in directly under her
ass again
as her drone comments that we are being
watched from below
because being a pervert is clearly
hilarious
number three a secret game over screen
disarmed
dishonored a game about being a
supernatural assassin who can morph into
everything from fish to rats and buck
again
encourages pure experimentation with
whatever's laid out in front of you do
you teleport around a level dropping in
on a target from above
maybe possess a god who's fired at you
freeze time and walk them in front of
their own bullet
it was an exemplary first installment
but this mentality of the developers
trying to think of everything first
extends to a peronic scene with calista
kerner the game's ai has patents and
dingy routines
callista disappears upstairs to her room
for a nice hot bath
as master assassin corvo you're free to
spy on calista through the keyhole
or barge right in and have a
conversation with her what's up
that's
[Music]
when it comes to genitalia death
stranding features a mode where you
essentially trap norman reedus sam
bridges into a room
and play around with him using emotes
perspective and other interactions
you can go to the toilet have a shower
make him pose
but each animation is triggered based on
where your camera is and what you're
looking at
case in point decide to stare at
reedus's crotch and he'll immediately
cover up
do so multiple times and he'll continue
to shield himself from you burning a
hole through his nether regions
but keep doing this and sam will get up
grab you by the neck and punch you
squeeze wow
now personally i can't see what kojima
was going for
quiet's role as a mute mercenary falling
in love with the legend of big boss was
supposed to be a call back to
love can officers on the battlefield
with quiet bowing out of the story by
speaking and killing herself
essentially putting an end to the
otherwise worthless romance that the
pair were supposed to have
only because venom snake doesn't talk or
at least talks very little
kojima loaded the phantom pain with
stupidly on the nose animations
to show that i was interested in our
hero dancing around half naked in the
rain is one then you take a shower with
harassing
suggestively is another but the absolute
peak of this stuff is the array of
things that quiet
will do in the game's helicarry based on
where your bomber
is at although even at 40 things get
super oh dear god please no one ever see
me watching this
quiet all but puts on a soft core strip
to his perception
by
[Music]
touching resolution she sacrifices
herself or her partner
knowing that speaking any word will
activate the parasites in her body
dooming her no matter what her final
words are used to save sake as she calls
in a helicopter
only to leave a tape behind that
explains her name before disappearing
altogether
it could have all been done so much
better but instead we've got a whole
bunch of tna
damage every time
let me know down in the comments your
own personal favorites and don't forget
to check out the waffles gaming podcast
dot com and i'll catch you soon this
video is not made for kids and it's got
a yellow dollar bill sign
is that fascinating
not made for kids or adult advertisers
apparently
so from what i learned about this is
that hideo kojima is the creep
especially because that arc goes from
characters being like stop looking at me
to be like just look at everything
yeah exactly snake come here man hideo
kojima's always had a bit of a
self-aware sense of humor when it comes
to
even in metal gear saw one there's like
weird things you could unlock and
you play like psycho mantis goes to like
this black screen just says like hideo
on it i i believe
yeah yeah and there are all those like
weird little like goofy posters and like
jokes you can find lying around
yeah there's always some bit of like
stuff where humor he has and even in
that death stranding footage of like uh
there are gonna be people who are gonna
try to look at his crotch so here's what
i could do the sexual parts are just
one element to the self-awareness of a
hideo kojima game now
that being said i'm not really defending
what goes on in
the final metal gear game that they
pointed out here on this list
it's
you know because i mean those games have
always been stylized and they've had
characters impractical costuming to say
the least but that
felt like the next level of like
heightened
strangeness for like she's in a full-on
g-string stripper bikini
out in the desert doing you know all
manner of espionage i've always known
that the culture in in europe and japan
when it comes to sexuality is very
different and nowhere near as like
who or taboo as it is in the states and
puritanic
so i mean what culture with them being
in the uk i bet they can get away with
doing more videos like this
maybe their you know the youtube ads and
the algorithm are not i was like no no
we're cool with that that's too violent
though we got an issue send us those uk
advertisers so much of this is kind of
similar in what you can do i've never
played the mass effect games and i like
the idea that you have this option
it doesn't just react to you being a
creep that it can actually lead into an
actual storyline and offset romance
storyline i think that's a really cool
thing to infuse
for a lot of these rpg like games
especially when they have decisions that
just stick like you that thing they
mentioned about if you make this certain
decision to have sex right now then you
won't be able to have romantic interest
in this character for the rest of the
game and i love when they put in those
like character history moments
or even the the reward you the
achievement you unlock in the james gunn
video game where
like for oogling too many times or
something like it just becomes a part of
your gaming history experience with that
game what is this
dating game with this guy in his 20s i'm
not sure i mean that's a whole niche of
gaming
that's out there that i i don't know
much about but i know exists where
you're just yeah doing like regular life
role play going through
a very specific scenario of yeah like
you're a college grad and you're trying
to make your way in the way it looks
like a very
entertaining dark version of the sims
i'd love to play sometime
like a sims memory some kind of yes
simulated girlfriend experience
or something my favorites are the ones
where it like messes with the storyline
but the dishonored game of how if you go
into the bathtub that'll actually
end the game because a lot of these are
little tiny moments or like hey
cut it out yeah hey stop it that's kind
of what you would expect if the game is
going to decide to implement something
where you can react to it but i love it
where
this can actually end the game for you
because you're dealing with a war
so if you get involved in this type of
sexual encounter that'll
mess up the consequences it can mess up
the future of the storyline unfolding
and so i love
that that is an actual element to the
game that might be my favorite in terms
of things they built in because a lot of
them are the same flavor of like oh the
character's just gonna be self-aware and
yeah and like cover up or something
which you know good on them for
for adding that in but yeah to just
completely end the game for a bad
decision
that would make sense you know it
tickles me it's just funny how there's
so many of these games
they have to work it's like i wonder
what the conversation is with these game
developers
we're gonna animate this girl who's like
very sexy half naked you know very
revealing clothing the whole time
there's gonna be a lot of
guys out there who are gonna try to get
a good a good look
you know so we gotta we gotta uh
acknowledge that and work
with that you know when it's weird too
when you're doing that you're going like
okay we already have this
hyper-sexualized character that we've
spent hours and days and months building
but how do we make it not quite luridly
sexy it's a fascinating thing because i
think with all technology especially now
you have to go
how are people going to use this for
perverted reasons yeah how do we
safeguard that
all right guys well what was your
favorite one on this list and what
culture
thanks for putting this video together
you guys are great at what you do this
was a really
funny addition i want to check out more
about culture gaming because this
specific side of what culture's been
recommended to me so many times and this
is my first one checking out the
wrestling they got the movies and now
they got this one and i think they even
have a couple one or two more subscribe
to the real rejects click that
notification bell to get notified
whenever we got a new youtube video
up make sure you subscribe to what
culture as well last but not least let's
do up
jt a friend of ours who has been
catching up on so much gaming during
this time of quarantine i'm sorry jt
you're getting this shout out today do
you know what the title of this video is
you know what the subject matter is
and now you're getting a shout out here
and i've gotten in trouble before for
making fun of the patrons during their
shout outs
99 of the time it goes over well and the
patrons to tell i'm just joking
one percent of the time it's really
backfired
so with that in mind let's see where we
land today
if there's anyone at our patreon page
who's a total creep when it comes to
video games
it's a hundred percent jt the naughtiest
one of them all
hot coffee patch all day long he puts
the naughty in naughty dog i'll tell you
that man
he is such a weirdo and he unlocks
things
mods leisure games larry you can use
your suit
i'm just telling you the guy is uh
someone you
you can't trust especially during this
time
hopefully you don't see this